resurgence aggressive aggressive  dangerous never stands up during the  game original exchange sacrificer  pre-retirement time and just enjoy chess  decent bullet unpredictable weird I  would say as a player for me shop wild  aggressive tricky aggressive and also to  pass the times creative very solid  positional master para de witte WQ  tricky Charcot lucky  prodigy champion star laughs class two  talented strong resurgence solid  amazingly talented positional player  cocky future contender yeah  dangerous myself legends ageless solid  legend unknown disease Reno's wisdom  difficult opponent I don't know just me  inspired a French maestro quick wits  French my good buddy  talent and stable machine a master of  preparation tough very focused academic  serious good over and plan I can't do  myself perfectionist Bloods genius  blitz artistic unpredictable Russian  grinder technically sound spider also  sold elegant spider British